so in the last couple videos I talked
about the multivariable chain rule which
I have written up here and if you
haven't seen those go take a look and
here I want to write it out in vector
notation and this helps us generalize it
a little bit when the intermediary space
is a little bit higher dimensional so
instead of writing X of T and Y of T as
separate functions and just trying to
emphasize oh they have the same input
space and whatever X takes in that's the
same number Y takes in it's better and a
little bit cleaner if we say there's a
vector valued function it takes in a
single number T and then it outputs you
know some kind of vector in this case
you could say the components of V are X
of T and Y of T and that's fine but I
want to talk about what this looks like
if we if we start writing everything in
vector notation and just since we see DX
DT air and dy DT here you might start
thinking oh well we we should take the
derivative of that vector valued
function the derivative of V with
respect to T and when we compute this
it's nothing more than just taking the
derivatives of each component so in this
case the derivative of X so you'd write
DX DT and the derivative of Y dy DT this
is the vector valued derivative and now
you might start to notice something here
okay so we've got one of those
components multiplied by a certain value
in another component multiplied by a
certain value you might recognize this
as a dot product it this would be the
dot product between the vector that
contains the derivatives the partial
derivatives partial F with respect to Y
partial of F with respect to X for
whoops don't know why I wrote it that
way so up here that's with respect to X
and then here to Y so this whole thing
we're taking the dot product with you
know the vector that contains ordinary
derivative dx/dt and ordinary derivative
dy DT
and of course both of these are special
vectors they're not just random the left
one that's the gradient of F gradient of
F and the right vector here that's what
we just wrote that's the derivative of V
with respect to T just for being quick
I'm going to write that as V prime of T
that's saying completely the same thing
as DV DT and this right here is another
way to write the multivariable chain
rule and maybe if you were being a
little bit more exact you would
emphasize that when you take the
gradient of F the thing that you input
into it is the output of that vector
valued function you know you're throwing
in X of T and Y of T so you might
emphasize that you take in that as an
input right and then you multiply it by
the derivative the vector valued
derivative of V of T and when I say
multiply I mean dot product right these
are vectors and you're taking the dot
product and this should seem very
familiar to you know the single variable
chain rule and just to remind us all
throw it up here if you take the
derivative of you know composition of
two single variable functions F and G
you take the derivative of the outside F
prime and throw in G throw in what was
the interior function and you multiply
it by the derivative of that interior
function G prime of T and this is super
helpful in single variable calculus for
computing a lot of derivatives and over
here it has a very similar form right
the gradient which really serves the
function of the true extension of the
derivative for multivariable functions
for scalar valued multivariable
functions at least you take that
derivative and throw in the inner
function which just happens to be a
vector valued function but you throw it
in there and then you multiply it by the
derivative of that but multiplying
vectors in this context means taking the
dot product of the two and this could
mean if you have a function with a whole
bunch of different variables so let's
say you have you know some f of X or not
f of X but F of like x1 and x2 and it
takes in a whole bunch of different
variables and it goes out to X 100 and
then what you throw into it is a vector
value from
that's something that's vector-valued
takes in a single variable and you know
in order to be able to compose them it's
going to have a whole bunch of
intermediary functions and all now you
can write it as X 1 X 2 X 3 all the way
up to X 100 and these are all functions
at this point these are component
functions of your vector valued v this
expression still makes sense right you
can still take the gradient of f it's
going to have a hundred components you
can plug in any vector any set of a
hundred different numbers and in
particular the output of a vector valued
function with a hundred different
components is going to work and then you
take the dot product with the derivative
of this and that's that's the more more
general version of the multivariable
chain rule and another cool way about
writing it like this is you can
interpret it in terms of the directional
derivative um and I think I'll do that
in the next video I won't do that here
so a certain way to interpret this with
the directional derivative